welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid I was having a conversation with
Mike Shulman over on my centripetal
force video about faking gravity it got
me thinking though how much like gravity
is it is there any way you can tell
you're in a spaceship or does it just
seem like a giant hamster wheel no no no
window who is the budget for that so
we've all seen it before
interstellar mission to Mars 2001 a
Space Odyssey part or all of a spaceship
spins which causes what seems like
gravity inside it is not actually
gravity here's what's really happening
let's say you're an astronaut floating
around in the spaceship when it begins
to spin you don't feel much of anything
as the spin gets up to full speed you
feel a slight breeze slowly pushing you
toward the outer edge eventually you
come into contact with that edge and
suddenly everything changes after
tumbling a little you notice the edge is
pushing on you just like a floor does on
the earth your body responds pushing
back on the floor and it feels a lot
like gravity but but it's not it's a
centrifugal force wait wait
haven't you said before the centrifugal
force doesn't exist well sure there are
outward forces they just don't act on
you the one in this spaceship acts on
the floor not on you but that's the one
you actually feel so it feels like it's
acting on you just stop thinking for a
moment and feel feel your own weight
where do you feel it if you're standing
it's in your feet if you're sitting it's
in your butt if you're lying down it's
mostly in your back it's underneath you
but that's not actually your weight
weight acts at your center of gravity
which is kind of in the middle of you
not underneath you know what you feel is
your bottom parts pushing down you don't
actually feel the outside world you only
feel how your body responds to it which
frankly is true of any feeling you have
perception is weird okay fine fine but
I'm definitely on the ground right now
are you sure what [ __ ] should I not be
we're on a spaceship or else did you
think a mad scientist would live
honestly no seriously I can't even
stabilize the camera see actually we're
spinning a little fast no wonder I've
been feeling so heavy all day thought
agitation went for breakfast speaking of
spinning too fast
if
gonna build a spinning spaceship let's
do it right we saw in this video that
the size of the circle matters if the
circle is too small then you're gonna
feel significantly heavier at your feet
than you will at your head
a spinning spaceship this small isn't
gonna work a working one is going to
have to be big like really big the
tallest person on the earth is a little
over 8 feet tall that's about two and a
half meters for the weight difference to
be less than 1% spinning circle has to
be about 503 meters across or 1,650 feet
it's about five football fields for 3
and 1/2 Giza pyramids or 110 Volkswagen
Jettas or 733 tube socks this also keeps
the ship from spinning too fast a little
under 2 revolutions per minute to be
specific otherwise it feel like a
carnival ride thanks to the Coriolis
effect we're talking dizziness nausea
and disorientation not fun in a place
you're supposed to be living okay so
assuming we built it well how do we tell
we're on a spaceship experiments we
might be spinning slowly but the
Coriolis effect is still there a little
bit
it only affects moving things though so
we got to make some stuff move jump well
that looked and felt pretty normal I
wonder what it looked like from the
outside weird they didn't really help
either hmm maybe we weren't moving fast
enough run as you run our good friend
Coriolis will make you feel heavier the
faster you run the heavier you'll feel
okay so that's going sideways I wonder
what happens when something goes up
a helium balloon weird it stopped in the
middle
it must be weightless up there climb a
ladder as you climb the fake gravity
slowly gets weaker until you get to the
center of the circle where it's gone
completely yeah that's probably the best
way to check just climb a ladder so if
you got to go to space would you want to
have gravity or would that just defeat
the purpose start a conversation in the
comments and until next time remember
it's okay to be a little crazy